[Musique]
salut c'est monsieur revol inscrits nous
allons vous parler depuis super
longtemps c'est le 1008 de chiens ont
mis un produit qui va arriver en france
d'ici quelques temps et qui pour
l'instant est disponible à l'import
alors à l'import j'ai un partenariat
avec la boutique dick mol qui m'a fait
parvenir d'ailleurs si vous intéresse il
ya un tarif très intéressant comme ça je
vous en parlais un peu plus tard dans la
vidéo directement chez dick mol un
produit que j'avais vraiment envie de
tester actuellement parce que le mail 8
est vraiment une promesse est une
promesse de la partie au mit alors il ya
deux versions il ya le 1008ha 2008
explorer edition est encore plus haut de
gamme le 1008 c'est vraiment la promesse
d'avoir un peu ce qui se fait de mieux
en terme de techno tout ça dans un
smartphone qui est vraiment pas cher
hyper abordable en 1500 euros et ça pour
le coup c'est vraiment super cool c'est
ce qu'on entend dans cette vidéo on va
regarder 6008 est vraiment un produit
intéressant est vraiment le produit
phare tente attendu étant vendus par
schumi est ce que c'est une bête de
compet
est ce que c'est un vrai produit
extraordinaire est ce que c'est un
cheval de course et ça on va le regarder
tout ça
et
j'aime beaucoup la marque sur wii parce
que je trouve qu'elle arrive vraiment
proposer des produits d'excellente
qualité à des tarifs défiant toute
concurrence
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant le
marché fasse on va pas se mentir et de
plus en plus concurrentiel il ya de plus
en plus de marques
beaucoup de marques chinoises qui arrive
énormément sur le marché de toute façon
qui était très clair c'est que dès lors
que huawei a l'air vraiment avoir des
chiffres intéressants en europe
on allait voir débarquer la concurrence
c'est chose faite chez en bio c'est dès
son arrivée en france il ya pas très
longtemps il ya au poker débarqué il n'y
a pas d'autre produit pas d'autres
marques continuent d'arriver époque où
c'est intéressant et c'est vraiment
intéressant pour le consommateur parce
que ça nous permet en tant que
consommateur d'avoir des produits
d'excellente qualité à des tarifs
défiant toute concurrence et ça qu'on
coup c'est vraiment excellent
le minutes alors levé 8 mois en tout cas
on aura déjà gardé un petit peu comme ça
à regarder
c'est ça que j'aime quand on ouvre et
des produits de cette qualité vous avez
plusieurs degrés de lecture vous ouvrez
vous avez directement là bas et je pas
vous le cacher c'est une version
chinoise c'est une version globale donc
vous inquiétez pas si vous l'achetez
directement par le lien me faisait me en
bas vous l'aurez en france et sans aucun
problème le packaging et chinois se
permettra d'apprendre la langue de l'
empire du milieu ça peut être très
intéressant pour vous quand on continue
de l'ouvrir on a à l'intérieur hop le
smartphone qui hélas 1008 belle bête je
le trouve vraiment très sympa teint de
design alors c'est vrai on va pas se
mentir
le design n'est pas complètement
révolutionnaire là dessus parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on a déjà vu revu
notamment depuis l'arrivée de l'iphone
10 l'année dernière le double module
photo à la verticale le capteur
d'empreintes digitales que j'ai ici
c'est par est un grand classique et ne
parlons pas de l'encoche que vous avez
ici de l'usb type c'est un haut parleur
mono est ici un microphone non je sais
pas lequel elle micro le cas les haut
parleurs ça peut être le point de regret
de ce produit parce que vous n'avez pas
de prise jack et ça pour le coup c'est
un peu dommage moi qui suis vraiment un
amoureux des castes un peu classique
avec la prise jack
l'agent n'est pas alors dans la boîte en
adaptateurs usb type s'est prise jack
c'est pas mal mais c'est très compliqué
parce que quand vous avez votre
smartphone vous le positionner comme ça
vous avez votre cap d'aillois de casques
tout de suite lourd sapant pas adapté
parce que j'avais vu mais là l'objectif
est quand même particulièrement
dégueulasse lé team pète ça vous
apprendra comme ça que nous à vous avez
beau folle à tout va bien
donc j'ai pris un casque je trouve que
vraiment ce système est tout sauf
pratique parce que vous branchez ça
comme ça ça pendouille c'est lourd
ici la savard tendance un petit peu
abîmés le câble ouais je suis vraiment
pas convaincu pour moi les marques et
prennent le pli de supprimer le port
jack veulent vraiment que le
consommateur passe au casque bluetooth
d'autant plus leur smartphone comme ça à
du bluetooth 5 3 0
donc c'est vraiment la volonté de
marques comme apple de passer aux castes
connectés notamment qu'est ce que beats
pour partie la remarque est là pour
shiomi il ya aussi un catalogue est
extrêmement large qui arrive en de plus
en plus en france et en europe en règle
générale et du coup je pense que la
volonté schumi c'est vraiment aussi de
passer au casque bluetooth ou bon
effectivement s'il y en a ce talent des
casques avec du jack et installateurs et
à finir par disparaître dans la boîte
effectivement bon ici votre usb usb type
c l'adaptateur secteur une version
chinoise
forcément vous allez ça il a été livré
avec l'adaptateur pour le recharger ça
fonctionne également que si on en a
besoin
vous avez à l'intérieur et pour le coup
c'est plutôt pas mal je sois livré avec
une coque transparente qui n'est pas
très belle mais qui une fois de plus est
ce qu'on ne le fait pas a le mérite
d'exister et donc lorsque vous avez un
smartphone vous n'avez pas produit
acheté du coq
ça peut quand même vous sauver la vie il
ya bien évidemment qu'une notice
d'utilisation
je vous invite bien évidemment apprendre
le mandarin
si ça vous intéresse justement puisqu'on
parle de dieu on va tester la puissance
là dessus voir s'il ya du son le niveau
est juste énorme
de quoi se rendre sourds par contre la
qualité pas mal
[Musique]
dussault et les haut-parleurs c'est donc
celui là bondues peu de viau duo
franchement ça marche y'a du son genre
dire est quand même sur ce smartphone
aux prix et surtout sur la qualité ce
qui est bien en avant par shiomi qu'on
n'ait pas de haut parleurs stéréo ici
c'est un peu point de regrets à côté de
ça ça fonctionne super bien il ya la
vraie puissance donc là dessus a pas du
tout de manque de puissance et lorsque
vous branchez avec ce petit accessoire
là sur une sortie casque ça marche super
bien parce que j'adore et qui est
vraiment très important c'est la qualité
de l'écran elle est vraiment juste top
c'est un écran amoled de 6,21 pouces
définition de 2240 pris par 1080 pixels
du fsd plus une résolution de 402 ppp
c'est un smartphone qui est extrêmement
lumineux que vous soyez en plein jour ou
alors que vous retrouviez des conditions
comme celles-là quelles conditions de
studio ça marche super bien
c'est vraiment extrêmement agréable que
vous regardez des vidéos vous mettez ce
que vous voulez ton expérience de jeu
soit qu'il est pas mal le coin comme
1145 encaisse tout bien il rame pas il
n'y a pas de soucis ne l'acpa on peut
vraiment profiter à 100% ça c'est vrai
que c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper
appréciable à des jeux même un peu
gourmand et on n'est pas du tout déçu
c'est top top top bon moi par contre je
suis pas un excellent joueur donc il va
falloir que je m'entraîne un peu sinon
on ne va pas le faire et ça smartphone
qu'elle a trait aux notes 218 1391 sûr
en tout ou lorsque le tester il a
effectivement cette note de 218 1391
mais lorsque vous regardez sur le site
directement deux ans tout tout vous avez
en numéro 1
le black shark de chez omis en deux le
guen +6 et en 3e 2008 autant dire que
mes huit et franchement avec l'a7 et
c'est là qu'on peut absolument rien lui
reprocher avec un qualcomm snapdragon
845 qui est à ce jour le meilleur sans
qu'on puisse trouver son marché vous en
avez d'autres
il exige de ce samsung il ya du kirin
aussi la puce à 11 chez apple mais là ce
snapdragon 845 est vraiment une bête de
compet couple assez giga de ram
il fonctionne à merveille vous n'avez
pas du tout de latence sur les jeux le
smartphone réagi extrêmement bien c'est
vraiment un excellent produit
si vous cherchez quelque chose avec de
la puissance vous serez absolument pas
déçu là dessus il est disponible soit en
64 j
à de stockage soit en 128 giga 64 giga
c'était franchement déjà à faire et vous
avez une batterie de trois mille quatre
cent millions par heure alors niveau
autonomie franchement il n'y a
absolument aucun problème
il absorbe complètement votre
consommation alors ça dépend une fois de
plus de votre utilisation aux
cotisations standards classiques il a
duré un jour et demi sans aucun problème
si vous n'êtes pas gourmand si vous
n'êtes pas tout le temps sur les réseaux
sociaux s'était pas tout le temps en
train de le solliciter en train de jouer
en permanence
il va vraiment pouvoir tenir un jour et
demi voire deux jours si vous êtes
plutôt cool sur une utilisation
intensive il encaissera sans aucun
problème une journée complète
d'utilisation et ça c'est vraiment un
très bon point voir nathan la photo la
vidéo
bon vous avez la chance vous emmener
avec moi pour aller voir directement ce
que ça donnait lors d'une journée à
l'extérieur
et franchement je dois reconnaître que
je suis vraiment bluffé ok donc là on
fait le test du smartphone on va
regarder maintenant de vous la caméra
arrière voir s'il intéressant on va se
faire un test caméra arrière caméra
avant voir si ça fonctionne bien malade
et du point de vue de la photo aussi
voir si le rendu intéressant là je
profite fondée sur une sortie opale sais
pas si vous connaissez c'est dans
l'allier plutôt cool donc on est choqué
c'est ensemble ils pensaient bien je
suis sur la caméra delphi je me vois
contre-jour histoire voir si ça va
bon normalement on n'est pas trop mal là
c'est forcément surexposé parce que le
soleil et dans cette direction mais
sinon
ça a l'air pas trop mal marché dites moi
ce que vous en pensez vous un
commentaire si ça vous paraît bien ou
pas gardé la hauteur je vous montre un
peu là vous avez un énorme étant plutôt
bucolique très sympa la stabilisation il
y en a une c'est pas mal alors vous
savez avec moi avec sa trompe tout de
suite ça pardonne pas trop mais ça a
l'air pas mal là le soleil est là si je
me tourne tout de suite savoir le retour
est plutôt pas mal quand même même du
point de vue de la caméra de celle fille
je me fous un peu à l'ombre derrière là
c'est un poil surexposé derrière la
salle cherche un peu voyez c'est
surexposé mois surexposé bon d'un autre
côté c'est normal je fais le point sur
moi c'est comme ça je fais le point
derrière voilà
mais c'est très très réactifs par contre
un sur la luminosité je fais quoi sur
moi c'est pas mal non j'ai quand même
plutôt pas mal et là maintenant je filme
avec la caméra arrière
là on se rapproche
[Musique]
qu'en est il maintenant faible
luminosité alors ici j'ai juste l'écran
d'ordinateur qu'il est clair je vais le
laisser ça ramène tout de suite beaucoup
de bruit sur l'image de notre côté c'est
pas smartphones qui est fait pour
travailler extrêmement bien faible
luminosité
ça marche sur la caméra de celle filles
ça fonctionne à peu près ça ramène
forcément du bruit des je pousse la
lumière ça n'a pas trop mal je pense que
vraiment ce smartphone
il est vraiment bien lorsque les
conditions de luminosité sont
complètement optimale c'est à dire que
ce que vous avez vraiment une très très
belle luminosité
ça n'a pas forcément être un smartphone
de vous lorsque la lumière est faible
par contre pour faire des photos vidéos
en bonne luminosité ça fonctionnera très
très bien dès que la lumière sera un peu
moins bonne c'est un peu moins bien ça
fera la sphère de l'autre côté quel est
l'intérêt d'aller faire des photos ou
des vidéos lorsque pas beaucoup lui du
côté de la photo le point qu'on pourrait
appeler lui reprocher c'est de dénaturer
parce qu'il va un peu sur saturer les
images c'est dans le côté très flatteur
c'est pas vraiment problématique mais
savez vous voyez directement à l'écran
et lorsque vous parlez vos photos elles
sont un poil sursaturé vous avez un
double objectif à l'arrière un
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels stabiliser
sur quatre axes ça c'est vraiment génial
avec une ouverture de f 1.8 et lotz un
tel objectif toujours 12 mégapixels qui
permettra notamment d'avoir un super
mode portrait avec une ouverture de f
2.4
vous avez un autofocus dual pixels ça
c'est génial pour vraiment qu'il est de
faire le point directement tout seul
vous avez lu hdr ya pas mal de
possibilités et notamment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle développé
par la surcouche 1008 de xiaomi vous
avez de la détection de scène vous avez
de la reconnaissance d'objets c'est
vraiment un truc qui marche super bien
jeter ça y est pas très longtemps le
minix 2es de shaolin je sais pas si vous
avez eu l'occasion de regarder cette
vidéo mais c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé
que ce smartphone était vraiment très
très très bon en termes de photos et de
vidéos et celui là ils lui ont pas
vraiment le pas il marche vraiment sur
ses pas il va peut-être un tout petit
peu plus loin en termes de photos mais
une fois de plus ses 10 points de détail
si vous cherchez un excellent photophone
nouvelles sur celui là
sur un budget aux alentours des 500
euros vous serez franchement pas déçu si
vous voulez encore plus en terme de
qualité vous avez p20 pro vous avez le
galaxy s 9 plus mais pour avoir un
excellent photophone pour des souvenirs
pour partager sur les réseaux sociaux
est vraiment dans d'excellentes images
le 1008 est parfait à la vente vous avez
une caméra de 20 mégapixels qui
permettra de déverrouiller votre
smartphone notamment on regarde alors
c'est pas un fait ça dit c'est un
faisceau noc avec de l'infrarouge par
contre c'est bluffant ça réagit
extrêmement rapidement et ça marche dans
le noir c'est vraiment bien il a bien
évidemment la reconnaissance faciale
il a des mots de beauté enfin parle de
petites options qui sont très sympas et
qui va rajouter un peu à l'expérience
utilisateur sur ce smartphone
la vidéo est pas en reste vous pouvez
filmer en 4k jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde et en full hd à 240 images par
seconde autant vous dire que pour avoir
des ralentis de qualité ça fera bien à
faire pour déverrouiller c'est
extrêmement rapide je le regarde ça
marche directement deuxième essai c'est
génial et même le 14h30 visite à
l'extrêmement rapide comme on doit
j'appuie ça marche tout de suite c'est
le top
en termes d'os il tourne sur un android
8 points aurait aucune surcouche les 8 9
points 5
on peut mettre une double carte sim
directement ici il a du bluetooth 5.0 et
dans l'absolu c'est vraiment un
excellent smartphone 6 de lui faire des
reproches passera en premier son design
non pas qu'il soit pas mort mais il
n'est pas hyper innovants chez au mit et
cliniques de l'ess avec les vaches
mangent plus loin a proposé une caméra
en bas ça c'était vraiment cool on
l'avait déjà sur le mythique de en tout
cas ça reste quelque chose de novateur
là dessus les effectivement rénovateur
comme beaucoup de 60 cette année il va
un peu pompeux les son fameux iphone 10
c'est un peu dommage
on sait notamment que chez home il ya
des vraies capacités d'innovation
derrière est ce qu'ils veulent
uniquement marcher sur les plates-bandes
d'apple notamment tout cas sur ce
produit là pour être sûr que d'un point
de vue esthétique qui se plante pas
qu'ils plaisent c'est aussi une
possibilité
est ce une stratégie qui en tout cas je
pense va être payante mais c'est vrai
que ce double module photo à la
verticale s'est déjà vu cette encoches
bon c'est déjà vu mais comme chez
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
constructeur néanmoins ça marche c'est
bien
niveau je peux pas dire le contraire
mais c'est vrai qu'il manque un peu
d'innovation et pour un smartphone
anniversaire en quelque sorte le mille 8
c'est un peu un point de regret autre
point de regret sur ce smartphone là
c'est le fait d'abord un haut parleur
mono et pas de haut parleurs stéréo
quand on arrive sur des produits haut de
gamme sont très clairement des produits
haut de gamme c'est un petit peu
décevant et le fait de ne pas avoir de
prise jack c'est très personnel c'est
pas forcément un handicap pour tout le
monde mais pour moi très personnellement
c'est bien parce que j'ai toujours mon
vieux casque et je suis encore attaché
au vieux port jack plutôt qu'elle ait
rajouté des connexions bluetooth au
niveau des casques bon après c'est un
sens c'est une technologie qui se
développe de plus en plus c'est moi qui
fais un peu les vieux dire là dessus
mais c'est vrai que je trouve ça quand
même plutôt cool point extrêmement
positif l'écran est vraiment superbe de
l'amoled magnifique les contrastes le
fond top les couleurs y perdit l'écran à
une luminosité qui complètement dingue
en plein jour là on est en plein été en
deux ans au mois d'août
vous pouvez aller en extérieur vous
profiter complètement de votre écran et
vous êtes pas du tout à galérer à cause
du soleil qui va effectivement vous
endettez au niveau de luminosité là
dessus le smartphone est génial il fait
absolument bien la faire en terme de
performance nous disent aussi le seul
dragon 845 couple à siéger qu'un drame
ça marche extrêmement bien
c'est vraiment un produit que je
recommande si vous voulez un excellent
photophone à un tarif défiant toute
concurrence vous pouvez aller sur le
1008 vous serez absolument pas déçu et
en termes de tarifs
il est vraiment positionné en version
globale sur mon partenaire vous pouvez
le trouver à moins de 450 euros vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
pouvait le voir parce qu on a les tarifs
en france on va retrouver le modèle en
64 giga à 499 avec 90 centimes donc
forcément un peu plus cher et le modèle
en 128 giga à 559 points 90 centimes
donc c'est vrai que celui là donc à 150
euros
il est vraiment positionné alors si
toutefois ça vous intéresse vous pouvez
y aller les yeux fermés il s'agit d'une
boutique italienne
donc vous êtes vraiment peinard en
termes de garantie garantie européenne
voilà un peu ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui
et sur ce 1008 je le trouve vraiment
bien et je ne peux que vous le
conseiller parce que je trouve que chez
tommy a vraiment fait du bon boulot show
me fait vraiment du bon boulot en règle
générale sur tous ses produits
ils ont un écosystème qui est
extrêmement complet même des fois un peu
complexe bien qu'en france ils
commencent à arriver tout doucement
notamment avec des smartphones ce qui
vend pas des catalogues en chine vous
allez voir c'est un truc de fou furieux
ils investissent dans des start up il
les accuse et puis après ils sortent
leurs produits sous leurs marques ce qui
fait qu'ils ont effectivement un
catalogue qui est extrêmement large qui
va de l'aspirateur ménages et à la
brosse à dents il ya plein de choses
assez c'est génial et ça permet d'avoir
des produits d'excellente qualité à des
tarifs vraiment très très bas par
rapport à la concurrence
dites nous ce que vous en pensez est ce
que ce 1008 vous fait de l'oeil
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter à savoir qu'il existe en 3
coloris l'âge et le modèle noir je crois
que vous l'avez remarqué mais il existe
également en bleu est également en blanc
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par ce même 8
est ce que ça pourrait être votre
prochain smartphone marquer ma tous les
dimanches à tout pour vous quels sont
les points positifs de ce smartphone
quels sont les points négatifs
qu'est ce qui vous ferait craquer qu'est
ce qui vous ferait craquer justement
pour pouvoir l'acheter
et puis quels sont les points de
réticences que vous avez donc vous
pouvez le marquer tout ça directement
aux commentaires je vous invite à vous
abonner parce que vous allez par v
retour plein plein plein de nouveautés
et comme surprises qui vont débarquer
d'ici quelques temps comme je vous le
dis la rentrée va être hyper dense il ya
plein de choses qui arrivent
un format revus corrigés pour la saison
numéro 2 ça va être super cool
d'ici là soyez sages vous invite à
laisser deux jolies pouces et puis on
reste connectés
soyez ça je vous embrasse il ya très
bientôt tiens
[Musique]